Hi.
My name is Barret Schloerke,
and I'm a software engineer
on the Shiny Team at RStudio.
Today, we're going to talk
about how plumber and future can
be combined to create
an asynchronous web API.
So let's consider an example
where we have two R functions.
Each function takes an
ID, but the first one
would do a fast calculation.
We can think it'll
take roughly 0 seconds.
And the second one will
do a slow calculation.
This one will take
about 10 seconds.
Plumber can take
these two functions
and decorate them using
roxygen2 like comments.
In this case, both
of these functions
can be accessed
using a get route,
but the first one will
be accessed under fast ID
and the second one will
be accessed using slow ID.
Any questions?
The ID will represent the order
in which the request was sent.
So if ID 1 will be
sent before ID 2,
let's see how plumber will
handle these requests.
In the receive
stage, the request
will be unpacked and be
prepped for processing.
In the processing stage, we
will execute the user function,
your function such as
the fast calculation
or the slow calculation.
And then finally,
once they are done,
we will bundle them up
in the response stage.
The receive in
response stage must
be handled by plumber because
that is very specific plumber
logic.
So let's look at
an example where
we have four
requests that arrive
at roughly the same time.
In order, it will go a fast,
then a slow, then a slow,
and then a fast.
Let's see how these execute.
Fast comes in, is
processed really quickly,
responded, and then done.
Slow comes in, is
received, processed,
but processing takes 10 seconds.
It is a long time.
A very long time.
But that's OK.
That's how long that
route takes, and then
will finally respond.
The second slow route has
been waiting patiently,
but will also take another
10 seconds to calculate.
Little long, but it's OK.
That's how long it takes, and
then finally it will respond.
And the fast route has
been waiting patiently,
processes really quickly,
and then responds
its original request.
So in total, this will
take about 20 seconds.
The first fast route will be
processed roughly instantly.
The second request,
which is a slow route
will take 10 seconds to execute,
and then it will respond.
But since R cannot process
multiple things at once,
slow 3 will have to wait
10 seconds before it can be
processed.
And finally, fast 4 had to
wait a total of 20 seconds
before it could
even be ingested.
In our current situation,
all four requests
completed in 20 seconds.
However, we accumulated
30 seconds of wait time.
Ideally, we would
like this to be zero.
Let's explore how future
can solve this for us.
So here we have our
existing plumber API code.
This is what it would look
like if we incorporated it
with future.
Future is an R package
made by Henrik,
which allows for parallel
and distributed computing
in R. Let's talk about
the three lines of code
that have been added
to our plumber API.
The first line of
code tells Future
what plans should be used.
In this case, we're going
to use a multi-session plan.
I'll leave it to you to
figure out which plan
is best for your situation.
The remaining code is
used to tell plumber
that, hey, this expression
needs to be calculated
using the future R package.
This allows for the main R
session to not be blocked.
A point of note, must return
the results of your future call
in your plumber router
for it to take effect.
Otherwise plumber will
not know what's happening.
Let's take a look at
the execution time
with plumber and future.
With just plumber alone,
it took 20 seconds total,
and we had 30 seconds
of accumulated time.
However, when we add in future,
everything is run immediately.
This allows for the
total execution time
to only take 10 seconds, and
we have zero accumulated wait
time.
This is the ideal
situation, and everything is
responding as fast as possible.
Fast 4 responded
20 seconds earlier,
and slow 3 also responded
10 seconds earlier.
This is very good deal.
Let's dive deep to see how
this execution is done.
Plumber has the three steps
that we talked about earlier--
receive, process, and respond.
This is all done on
the main R session.
Only one route can
be there at a time.
Future, however, can
launch multiple R sessions,
and we'll call them
worker 1 and worker 2.
In our use case,
we're only going
to be using them in
the processing step.
So we must receive and respond
from the main plumber R
session, but we can
offload the processing
to the future workers.
Let's watch to
see how this goes.
Fast comes in, is
processed, and we respond.
Nothing new.
No surprise.
Slow 2 is offloaded
immediately to worker 1.
Since the main session
is free, then slow 3
can be offloaded to worker 2.
This allows fast 4 to
be processed and respond
immediately.
Once slow 2 is done, it can
respond same with slow 3.
That's a lot faster and
a lot more going on.
But in the end, we
have no wait time.
Let's look at that again.
This allows fast 4, since it's
not being blocked by slow 2
or slow 3, fast 4 can
respond immediately
at the zero second mark.
And since we can do
things in parallel, slow 3
is also being processed at
the same time as slow 2.
Both of these do not
block the main R session.
This is ideal.
However, there are
some limitations
what we can do with
plumber and future.
One, you have to manually
add your future call
where we deem appropriate.
This is because
adding the future call
adds a little bit of
execution time to each route.
Now, if your execution time
is normally in the seconds,
and adding a quarter
of a second does not
mean much to you, then great.
I think future is a perfect
candidate for that route.
However, if adding a quarter
of a second to your execution
time dramatically
increases it, maybe
adding future maybe
not the best idea.
And instead, will just keep
it in the main R session.
The other one we
have to remember
is that processing power is
finite and memory is finite.
We cannot necessarily launch
100,000 workers on one laptop.
That would be a
little bit of overload
either with processing
power or the memory.
One of the two will limit what
you can do on your machine.
I'd like to thank
you for listening in
on how plumber and future Can
be integrated to help you create
an asynchronous web API.
Remember, offload
your slow routes
using plumber
expressions, and this
will help keep your main plumber
worker available to process
incoming requests.
Thank you.